[Música]
y en directo a América edición nocturna
es momento de conocer Cuáles son las
principales noticias internacionales en
materia económica y por eso nos acompaña
Juan Pablo luco muy buenas noches Juan
buenas noches Santiago llegó el momento
de hablar de economía así es y
comenzamos hablando de Ucrania No que
dijo que necesita mano de obra para lo
que es la reconstrucción del país verdad
así es Santiago Pues no sé si usted
Recuerda que ya hemos hablado de cuánto
dinero Ucrania ha dicho que necesita
para esa reconstrucción y también que
muchos países han donado Pues a este
proyecto Pues bien Ahora la cifra tiene
que ver con cuántas personas se necesita
para que esa reconstrucción sea una
realidad quien dijo que serían en total
4,5 millones de personas las que
tendrían que incorporarse al mercado
laboral de Ucrania por lo menos en los
próximos 10 años esto teniendo en cuenta
que antes de la guerra Ucrania ya sufría
de escasez de mano de obra en ciertos
sectores y este escenario se agravó con
la salida de 6 millones de personas del
territorio de ese país cuando Ucrania
pasamos a Rusia al país Invasor la ONU
le está dando algunas alternativas y
posibles soluciones en este intento para
salvar no el acuerdo de exportación de
granos a través del mar Negro Así es
propuestas para que este acuerdo no se
caiga la propuesta del secretario
general de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez
consiste en levantar las trabas que
afectan a las transacciones financieras
rusas a través del Banco Agrícola ruso
una solución que da el jefe de la ONU a
Putin con la intención de salvar este
acuerdo con el que se abastece de granos
y cereales a muchos países del mundo y
lo hemos también revisado en varios
momentos recientemente Rusia ha
amenazado con no seguir con el acuerdo y
una de las principales razones Es que
este país fue sacado del sistema Swift
que regula la mayoría de transacciones
financieras internacionales recordemos
que el acuerdo del mar Negro consta de
dos partes una para facilitar la salida
del cereal ucraniano y otra para hacer
lo mismo con el cereal Ruso y sobre todo
con sus fertilizantes pero
Moscú se ha quejado desde el primer
momento de que esta segunda parte del
acuerdo no se está cumpliendo y por eso
Antonio guitarres dice que quiere
garantías veremos como danza porque es
clave para gran parte de la comunidad
internacional jugada en ese acuerdo Así
es vamos ahora con Los indicadores de la
jornada que nos dicen Pues empezamos con
Estados Unidos porque este miércoles el
optimismo invadió Wall Street y sus tres
principales indicadores cerraron con
ganancias luego de que se conociera que
la inflación anual de junio se ubicó en
el 3% desde el 4% que alcanzó en mayo y
el optimismo llegó porque ese es el
décimo mes consecutivo de que la
inflación llega con Esta caída en otras
noticias que afectaron los mercados de
Norteamérica el banco de Canadá subió
las tasas de interés a sus máximos de 22
años cuando aumentó Los costos
deudamiento en 25 puntos básicos por
segunda vez en dos meses América Latina
tuvo un cierre mixto con Brasil y
Colombia reportando ganancias en sus
principales indicadores mientras que
México cerró con una pérdida del 0,34
por ciento en Guatemala los ministros de
economía y energía dejaron el gobierno
de yamatei a algo que elevó la
incertidumbre y afectó a los indicadores
Cuál es hoy la cifra del día hoy las
cifras son los 92 billones de dólares a
los que aumentó la deuda pública mundial
en 2022 lo que supone una cifra nunca
antes alcanzada y que se dio en gran
parte por el endeudamiento de los
gobiernos para contrarrestar la crisis
causada por la pandemia del covid 19
algo que le está pasando factura a todos
los países Juan Pablo comí como siempre
excelente y completísima Crónica
económica Gracias mañana con mucho más
Santiago